Good afternoon.
My name is Toby Dawson.
My name is also Kim Bong-seok.
I'm a freestyle skier and I'm an Olympian.
I'm a Korean by birth yet I'm also an American.
That last sentence contains an entire story about the true potential of Pyeongchang 2018...
...and the legacy of "New Horizons".
And it's why I'm so honored to be here today.
I was born in Busan, South Korea in 1978.
When I was three years old, a couple adopted me in the United States.
Luckily for me, they lived in Vail, Colorado.
My parents introduced me to skiing at an early age,...
...as a means to adapt to a new family and a new culture.
As all of you have witnessed many times before,...
...sports can be transformative for a young person.
It certainly was for me.
Skiing was a means of expressing myself in a positive way.
It gave me the confidence to believe in myself...
...as a kid, as a teenager, and as a young man.
That is the true gift of sport:...
...it provides hope.
Thinking back on it now, I realized that had I remained in Korea,...
...I may not have had the opportunity to be an Olympian.
You see, Korea simply did not have the resources to provide someone like me...
...with the chance of competing in the Winter Games.
The very thing that winter athletes take for granted...
...in Europe and North America, simply did not exist in my home country.
That's what this bid is all about ladies and gentlemen.